[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le plateau date année d'interdire je
reçois jean henri guillemin pour trop
beau pour être vrai c'est sur les faux
dans l'art hugo jacomet pour son beau
livre intitulé souliers une passion
masculine avec des photos dans dit julia
constance debré pour son nouveau roman
love me tender et le pianiste guillaume
vincent pour son nouvel album black list
et l'on commence tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui la caractérise nos
invités répondent comme toujours en
images on va commencer par vous
constance de bruit votre image à vous la
voici
ça date pas du début du xxième siècle
mais n'ont pas tout à fait je me disais
qu'on peut toujours voir nos existences
effectivement se déroulant dans les
particules a été de l'époque mais aussi
aussi les voir autrement au regard de ce
que raconte l'odyssée et l'iliade c'est
à dire sur la même chose c'est la guerre
et le voyage la voyager les épreuves et
la main et on s'aperçoit très bien qu'en
lisant c'est pour ça qu'on les lit
toujours c'est que d'une certaine
manière on vit toujours la même chose
aussi et dans le cas des grands artistes
enfin au mr on peut le qualifier comme
tels
c'est toujours aussi beau et toujours
aussi vrai est une odyssée pays ami lou
de bilan ou 500 en 400 ans liste cdh
soit aussi beau toujours aussi vrai au
fond c'est ça la différence entre l'art
et la culture
quelque chose c'est l'air du temps vous
guillaume vincent votre image à vous et
bien moi j'ai toujours cette réflexion
devait dire aujourd'hui qu'on est un peu
quelque part obsédé par l'image par les
salles fille instagram les réseaux
sociaux tout ça etc
et puis c'est vrai que par exemple quand
on écoute et un 33 tours on écoutait
vraiment l'artiste
et puis aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya beaucoup de d'image comme ça un
peu superflu et moi j'essaye
personnellement quand je travaille de
mettre mon téléphone de côté alors je
dis ça s'est passé pas une critique
parce que je suis le premier à prendre
17 filles parfois mais c'est quelque
chose que j'ai remarqué c'est un constat
c'est un constat d'aujourd'hui canton
quand je pense au monde aujourd'hui en
tout cas d'un point de vue artistique je
vois plus d'image que je n'écoute de
musique est souvent août
connaît la musique par l'image d'abord
par la vidéo c'est un moyen
effectivement de la rendre accessible
activement auprès de tout le monde
jean claude jeanjean louis game 1 vous
aussi un téléphone portable je vois
qu'on reste il ya une récurrence du
téléphone portable voir cette émission
ça c'est une photo que j'ai prise au
louvre devant la mona lisa et vic te
ment il y avait une foule immense était
là c'était il ya un an et demi c'était
encore dans ce temps là dans la salle il
y avait une foule alors on n'était pas
calibré c'est à dire qu'on avait pas
trois secondes pour prendre le oui parce
que maintenant wayne maintenant vers les
gens au bout d'un centre à ce compte
pour faire votre votre photo et ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'effectivement
c'est plus même plus la mona lisa qu'on
photographie c'est le
le touriste lui même qui s'auto graphie
pour dire j'ai l'âge il fut vice hui est
un peu le côté pélérinage en quelque
sorte et la mona lisa on la voit très
peu d'ailleurs on le voit très mal sur
la photo est derrière ces vitres
blindées et j'en ai profité pour me
demander si elle était vraiment vrai si
c'était la vraie qui étaient là ah oui
parce qu'après des évidemment pour
éviter un attentat ou que sèche après tu
mets ce que vous êtes demandés pourquoi
c'est le tableau le plus célèbre du
monde pourquoi celui-ci
je pense qu'il est devenu célèbre quand
on l'a quand il a été volé en 1912
travail par là et tout d'un coup j'ai
pas l'attention c'est s'est précipitée
d'abord voler un tableau au louvre
c'était déjà un fait très important et
je crois que la presse la presse
quotidienne s'en est emparé harris est
resté pendant plus d'un an et pendant
plus d'un an
on l'a oublié aujourd'hui mais c'est
vrai que pendant plus d'un an la
modéliser on te plaît énormément
il veut jacomet votre image à vous elles
datent pas non plus d'une vingtaine et
la date pas non plus du 21e siècle c'est
un c'est une toile que j'aime beaucoup
qui est d'un peintre français et mais
morrow je crois que c'est 1880 et c'est
un à parabole du bon samaritain très
cosy l'hérault non pas émile moreau ses
aînés je pense que c'est non c'est non
toujours est il que pour remettre cette
chose dans le contexte est pour pour
vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai longtemps
hésité mais j'ai choisi cette image
c'est à mon avis ce qui manque le plus
ce que notre époque j'ai pris un peu le
contre-pied de notre question on remet
ça dans le contexte on est dans les
évangile selon saint luc et quelqu'un
demande à jésus qui lui dis aime ton
prochain ou même ton voisin ça dépend
comment on dit love you lie en anglais
ou m l'autre ou m l'étranger et j'ai dû
lui répond par cette parabole que je
trouve moins magnifique et qui dit tout
sur notre époque assez la parabole de ce
monsieur qui a été attaqué par des
bandits et qui gît à moitié mort alors
tout coin du chemin comme ça sur la
route de jérusalem est un traître juive
passe et va pas changer de trottoir
l'époque est peut-être pas de trottoir
mais enfin il détourne le regard et puis
ensuite aller vite juive passe une
deuxième fois et se détournent et
finalement c'est un samaritain qui vient
aider ce monsieur qui vient panser ses
plaies
c'est ce qui est important de comprendre
c'est que le samaritain en question
c'était la relation entre les juifs et
les samaritains et c'est là où le cette
chose est très belle sait que c'était
vraiment de plug presque ennemi c'est à
dire que les juifs détestait les
saratars elle est dégoûtée n'aime pas ce
qu'ils étaient pour eux l'image de
l'impureté c'était des impies des gens
qui comment dire qu'ils qui vénérait
d'autres lieux etc
et pourtant c'est ce soir étant là qui
allait lui même n'est même pas n'aimait
pas les juifs qui allait sauver et à les
payer une auberge les panser les plaies
pour moi c'est représentatif de l'autre
au sens large
l'autre aujourd'hui on est dans une
époque où l'autre c'est soit l'étranger
soit se réfugier soit la personne qui a
pas les mêmes opinions politiques que
nous les mêmes orientations sexuelles
que nous et c est aujourd'hui je pense
que 7,7 cette notion de l'autre l'autre
c'est celui qui est là et qui a besoin
de nous et il nous semble que c'est que
justement grandement notre époque et
bien commençons
[Musique]
jean-louis game 1 vous êtes docteur en
histoire de l'art fait partie des
fondateurs de beaux-arts magazine et de
l'objet d'art vous enseigner l'histoire
de l'art à la sorbonne et vous publiez
trop beau pour être vrai aux éditions le
passage dans lequel vous raconter des
histoires de fo qui ont émaillé
l'actualité depuis plusieurs siècles
il y en a de plus en plus des histoires
de faux en fait mais je pense que je
peux faire un deuxième volume très
facilement louis c'est dingue ça
n'arrête pas quoi dire que ça et encore
quand il va voir l'imprimante 3d
vraiment dans tous les foyers ça va être
extraordinaire fruits avec photoshop on
avait déjà beaucoup s'amuser alors le
problème du le faut a beaucoup évolué
avec le temps
pendant la renaissance dites-vous ont
considéré qu'un faussaire c'est
quelqu'un qui avait réalisé un aimable
tour de force vive mais aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit un crime
voilà
mais en fait à l'époque il ya un
changement du statut de l'artiste une
certaine façon l'artiste était plutôt un
artisan à l'époque dans un dans un
atelier son maître travailler à la
commande y réaliser un portrait réalisé
un pays un paysage dessinée à tel
endroit précis donc s'il y avait un côté
artisanal et quand on est artisan et
bien on copie de maître pour apprendre
un peu sa manière sa façon et les
techniques et l'a d'ailleurs un des
premiers faux réalisé par michel-ange un
prince médicis lui a dit je te conseille
de l'enfouir dans le sol quand tu quand
ils restructurent leur sortira on pourra
croire que c'est une statue antique et
une gendre a beaucoup plus cher qu'il a
fait il a vendu un cardinal à rome et
donc à l'époque tout le monde trouvait
ça plutôt plutôt rigolo et ça a changé à
partir du moment où l'artiste et il
n'est plus un artisan m'avait devenir un
individu isolé en d2 même un saint ces
zones et 1,5 aujourd'hui devient un
génie il va devenir
il va il va être venir la réincarnation
du sein c'est lui qui va être le sien
moderne à peu près vers al dante est
donc faux si on aime bien les faussaires
si on les trouve souvent
on trouve ce sont des héros parce qu'au
fond ils se moquent du clergé et le
faussaire se moque du clergé car
j'essaie d'agir les conservateurs de
musées les experts les cierges énergies
d'aujourd'hui qui organise les grandes
messes et quand des expositions les
musées ont remplacé les églises le
dimanche à 4 heures c'est pas on essaye
aller au musée avant la fermeture de la
caisse comme autrefois on allait à la
messe avant avant l'élévation cette
illustration qui figure de votre livre
ce monde-là faire de la tiare du louvre
alors c'est quoi rêver mais nous lisons
grosso modo c'est un cetain objets
d'orfèvrerie qui a été présenté aux
conservateurs du louvre par deux
marchands de marchands qui venait
justement de d'odessa et et il l'avait
présentée au musée autrichien qui en
avaient pas voulu on à quelle époque là
on est en 19 en 1896 c'est une époque ou
encore la lutte franco-allemande franco
prussienne était dans tous les esprits
si les allemands avaient refusé de nous
on sera beaucoup plus malin on va
l'acheter voilà une d une des raisons
qui fait qu'à un moment on se précipite
et là c'est la caricature et drôle on
voit la tiare dans sa petite vitrine et
à l'époque un fumiste dire un peintre un
peintre de montmartre un peintre rigolo
avait prétendu avoir été l'auteur de
celle de la tiare alors le monsieur
arrive alors tout et de montmartre ici
et là et les deux gardiens qui était à
l'époque en uniforme ne répond pas du
tout moi je suis de gauche et je suis
des batignolles alors alain cave où les
allemands ont été moins boisée futé
c'est qu'avant mais gagnent alors vendre
mais garenne après après l'occupation de
la hollande est accusé d'avoir vendu un
vermeer à göring donc il a vendu un
trésor national donc on va lui qui avait
bombardé rotterdam
oui eh ben oui horrible le patron de la
luftwaffe et et pauvres qu'est ce qui
réveille dit mais non je lui ai vendu
info je suis un moment mais comme il
avait vendu un trésor national du mérite
et le peloton d'exécution
contre le peloton d'exécution et avouer
que depuis cinq ans que dis-je depuis 20
ans il faisait défaut il faut vers mais
il a donc à jouer et il a fallu qu'ils
en fassent un sous les yeux de la police
c'est ce qu'on croyait pas jean premier
avait été un frein un événement national
c'étaient les plus beaux mais l'envers
du monde c'était pour le juge il est le
jubilé de la reine donc toute la classe
politique
et là on le voit la séduit ses ventes
des garennes est très rigolo et est donc
le procès a été un succès pour lui parce
que deux faussaires il était devenu
celui qui avait berné goering wii qui
était pas vrai connaisseur pareil cas la
villa il avait réuni d'ailleurs la plus
belle collection qu'on puisse imaginer
il faut dire ça lui coûtait pas cher
c'était assez facile alors vous dites
qu'il ya deux types de faussaires il ya
le fabricant à rennes et puis à le
metteur en scène c'est pas la même chose
il ya le cas intéressant de bill palau a
beaucoup parlé c'était il ya deux trois
ans on va le voir la ville palau c'est
un expert célèbre qu'est ce qu'il va
faire il va il va faire fabriquer par à
fabriquons élus on connaît même pas son
nom et non partisan donc certes artisans
meilleurs artisans de france oui voilà
dans l'histoire c'est pas lui qui est
important c'est 1000 palau puisqu'il
fait fabriquer des fausses chaise qui
fait acheter par le jeu le château de
versailles va louer le savent en le
sachant et en plus c'est quelqu'un qui
avait son pied partout où il travaillait
pour un des meilleurs antiquaires de
paris l'avait fait une thèse sur le
siège il était expert auprès de la cour
d'appel
il avait rédigé un des catalogues du
louvre on peut pas imaginer y était nous
étions ensemble confrères 1 à la
sorbonne il donnait des cours également
à la sorbonne
donc on pouvait pas mettre une seconde
en doute son opinion s'il disait ce sont
des chaises du xviiie c'était des chefs
vous pourrez regarder même pas imaginer
que les jupons de marie antoinette avait
frôlé les chaises en question étaient
d'accord tout de suite oui c'est ça donc
le le métro c est très important il ya
john drew aussi john drew lui qui fait
des défauts certificat
alors ça c'est encore plus vicieux lui
va dans les archives il pique des
documents les arches il va les remplacer
par d'autres documents plus intéressant
pour les oeuvres qu'il était en train de
fabriquer ailleurs et ils peuvent même
faire fabriquer des oeuvres à ces médias
cre comme les certificats sont offerts
physique à son bon la pologne est
toujours la provenance et la façon si la
provenance est excellente
la façon de table on vous dit que le
fabricant n'ayant ne connaît pas
toujours le destin des défauts qu'il est
en train de fabriquer il sait pas
forcément que ça marche de l'espoir où
il découvre que son l'intermédiaire l'a
bernée qu'il a vendus sont pas remplies
green goal com angleterre sont rendus
compte que les petits dessins qui
faisait pour un marchand était vendu
très cher qui en a qui sont retrouvés
dans des maisons de ventes importantes à
partir de ce moment-là il reprend un peu
sur lui et c'est lui qui décide de
devenir à la fois le fabricant et le le
le malin qui sait qu'à l'époque on
cherchait telle chose et voilà
il va donc la faire pour l'expert en
questions les meilleurs dites vous mais
meurt fossé comme ceux qui sont à la
fois le fabricant et le métro ça va oui
alors le meilleur un des meilleurs c'est
20 de médias rennes et connaissez par
coeur l'oeuvre de de vermeer et qui
savait surtout ce qu'on attendait le
chaînon manquant un tableau qui va
permettre à l'historien d'art d'établir
une nouvelle catégorie
il n'a apporté un truc de 1 m 30 de long
et on a causé c'était le plus beau
vermeer c'est le petit aussi n'a jamais
vu des comme ça disait l'asthme et mais
vous dites aussi que c'est parce qu'au
fond le faussaire de génie il va
rajouter un peu de notre époque donc son
faux tableaux de la renaissance de la
table tous les cas qui fonctionne que ce
soit des faux bijoux de la renaissance à
19e
on la refait beaucoup 19e le faux
vermeer les faux max ernst et un
récemment les faux max ernst présenté
par bell traki le fossé rhénan
ils ont toujours quelque chose qui va
faire qu'on y trouve plus beaux que les
autres sans le savoir pour voir envoie
un max à ce qu'il est beau mais il est
beau parce qu'il est qui correspond
exactement la vision du faussaire qui
est la même que la vision du moment mais
trente ans après on y croit plus les jo
guillaume vincent il ya défaut en
musique
oh boy des fosses partition c'est assez
rare quand même
non je pense pas que j'ai passé l adagio
d'albinoni ah oui la dette je deviens
cas de faux mais là il essaye même pas
de le faire passer pour un vrai stade
composteur il vient de quelques dot
d'albinoni créer un adagio et oui il
l'appelle l'adagio d'albinoni ça se vend
comme des petits pains mais c'est lui
qui touche parce que tout le monde sait
enfin les gens qu'ils savent que ça
dépens d'albi le 10 avril que six soirs
comme ça effectivement d'ailleurs il ya
quelques pièces de frédéric chopin
voilà qui sont remis en cause parce que
l'on pense que et sur certaines pièces
moi je suis assez convaincu certaines
pièces n'ont pas été vraiment écrite par
chopin mais peut-être par un de ses
élèves où il ya quelques oui voilà
quelques petites fossettes et comme ça
mais c'est assez rare je pense qu'en ce
qui concerne la musique classique mais
après il ya beaucoup d'influencé c'est à
dire que d'un point de vue à monique au
niveau d'une mélodie souvent les
compositeurs vont vous 13 ans influence
est très fort et plus parfois vont créer
quasiment la même chose quand on regarde
par exemple liste on peut croire qu'il a
parfois cité ben étoffe parfois cité
chopin rachmaninov
il est arrivé après et puis bon bah
c'est une grande chaîne évidemment mais
après c'est le fait qu'on est influencée
vous vous dites j'ai envie à une main
que les faussaires aussi médiocre
souhaitez vous aussi géniaux soit il ne
serait rien sans les dupes
il faut les ducs d'angers le plein c'est
le couple c'est normal qu'ils meurent
dans vie d'abord à leonardo passion
évidemment envie de vinci va finir par
se retrouver qu'à faut attendre le
château de versailles vos apps voulait
veut toujours d'ailleurs meublé château
comme il était avant les grandes ventes
de la révolution dont 15 en 1789 et une
conservatrice disait il en passe
régulièrement en vente
nous sommes en permanence à l'affût
quand on est en permanence à l'affût on
va tirer sur l'âne comprendra pour un
lion comme lorsqu'il ya un peu ça oui
c'est ça et au fou quand on leur dit au
fait c'était un faux c'est au ils ont
beaucoup de mal à y croire mais oui et
puis c'est horrible parce qu'on a
tellement adoré ce tableau et et suda
parce que on vous révèle que c'était pas
vermeer mévente mais goren vous ne
l'aimé plus alors il ya deux catégories
ya ceux pour qui l'oeuvre s'effondre il
ya ceux qui continuent à y croire non
non c'est super on sait pas très bien si
c'est pour se sauver leur peau humaine
va sauver leur rôle ou si c'est ou si
c'est sincère
au fond il faut se présenter avec le bon
objet au bo
moment au bon moment voilà parce que le
22 mai guérenne les inédits maïs
aujourd'hui on n'y croit pas quand ton
voisin mais comment ils ont pu prendre
ça pour un vermeer mais on comprend ils
ont reprises à parce que les historiens
d'art ont cherché un un vermeer plus
caravagesque ensuite c'était un nouveau
héros national nouveaux peintres
important dans les années 30 où les
nationalismes en europe
voilà donc le public est arrivé il a
fallu mettre des tapis pour transformer
la salle en chapelles et c'est devenu
une nouvelle grande oeuvre nationale et
enfin vous dites qu'il ya le milieu le
clergé justement elle est très très rare
que milieux fassent de la publicité à
des affaires de faux vous citer un
exemple la galerie google wave à paris
qui a osé dire afrique et inde un des
bons exemples avec quelques musées vous
musées étrangers levier n'est levier
n'est organisé une exposition sur les
faux le british muséum également mais ça
serait bien qu'ils en font mais la
galerie c'est de cela s'était alors
agacé des commerçants il voyait notre
attention là une époque où le marché du
bijou renaissance était un peu vacillant
parce qu'il y avait trop de faux s'il y
avait eu trop de bijoux améliorer ou
inventés au 19e les gens se disaient
mais où est ce qu'on va en trouver dont
ils ont fait une exposition avec les
vrais bijoux et les foyers les faux
bijoux en montrant des exemples c'est à
dire des des démos qui avaient été
fabriqués par tel fabricant ou d'autres
oeuvres du même faussaires donc c'était
intéressant de voir de voir la
confrontation des deux gauches est comme
s il ya des fausses chaussures de très
très grande bottier ou là alors oui des
millions 1
mais la différence c'est qu'on se
rencontre tout de suite au bout de deux
semaines et partent c'est à dire il ya
même des fabricants en italie qui ont
inventé des semelles avec des fausses
couture c'est à dire que quand vous
mettez à quand vous regardez un beau
souliers avec une vraie couture faite à
la main ou même à la machine mènerait
couture et des gens des petits malins
qui ont décidé qu'ils allaient faire des
prêts couture mais c'est en fait tout et
c'est une arnaque littéralement est en
fait ce sont des souliers qui sont qui
sont collés tout simplement mais là vous
vous en apercevez un petit peu plus
rapidement tout de même je pense qu'au
bout de deux ou trois semaines vous avez
la semaine placent mail qui maillent
dans le domaine du soulier c'est un peu
différent on en parlera tout à l'heure
c'est un michelin ensuite une seconde
dans l'artisanat et l'art mais il ya
quand même quelque chose que la
chaussure le soulier reste un objet
utilitaire donc il n'y a pas cette
notion d'artiste tout est copiable à
l'infini trop beau pour être vrai c'est
le titre du livre de jean louis game 1
qui vient de paraître aux éditions le
passage
[Musique]
hugo jacomet vous êtes l'auteur d'un
célèbre blog en plusieurs langues
intitulé parisienne gentleman
c'est devenu un livre ensuite qui a eu
beaucoup de succès vous avez des chaînes
youtube en français en anglais sur
l'élégance masculine vais plus de cent
mille abonnés et là vous publiez
souliers chez gründ alors c'est un très
gros livre je les prie avec moi qu'on
voit voyez c'est ça pèse c'est très gros
voilà avec des photos dans ledit julia
on va en voir les illustrations derrière
moi pour qu'on en parle vous ces
sous-titrés une passion masculine alors
la vôtre vad jusqu'à au fait qu'on
n'utilise jamais le mot chaussures ont
dit souliers c'est quoi la différence
alors la différence alors ya beaucoup de
théories sur le sujet on va pas faire
deux heures sur la sémantique autour de
la chaussure à disons que le premier à
avoir parlé de souliers c'est roger
vivier qui était un très grand bottier
mais pour dame qui faisait donc des des
talons hauts les plus beaux escarpins du
monde à l'époque qui c'est vrai que moi
pour moi on dit des souliers de femmes
des chaussures d'homme louis alors
c'était vrai jusqu'à on va dire le gars
berluti dans les années 80 qui a décidé
de dire voilà aujourd'hui il faut qu on
réinjecte dans le soulier masculin dans
la chaussure masculine un tout petit peu
de rêve un tout petit peu d'esthétique
un tout petit peu d'imagination un tout
petit peu comment dire d'attrait et donc
elle a réussi le tour de force et drôle
crois qu'on est dans les années 80 vous
souvenez la sphère roland dumas et
toutes ces choses là période un petit
peu plus tard voilà et donc elle a
inventé réinvente alors c'est un peu
snob début de dire souliers pour 1,7 à
sauf que depuis il ya quand même ça a
quand même une dimension un tout petit
peu plus précise on souliers sert à
faire la distinction entre ceux dont on
parlait tout à l'heure entre un soulier
fabriqué par un gamin aux philippines
collet pour 5 euros et vendu très cher
sous des grands noms de marques parfois
est un vrai produit fait à la main par
un artisan il ya dans mon livre les
souliers qui demandent 80 heures de
travail à l'absence 59 30 50 ans je vois
que vous avez lu le lit
il y a effectivement l'intérieur ce
bouquin par exemple on pense à stéphane
gimenez à bordeaux c'est à peu près 80
joueurs partis et je dois dire que dans
ce cas choisir votre sélection avoue des
plus beaux souliers du bon oui alors
peut pas faire mieux
c'était une sélection qui était pas très
difficile à faire parce que si vous êtes
un petit peu intéressés par le sujet on
va dire que là on parle en grande partie
de les gens qui travaillent encore sur
mesure à la main donc ce sont des gens à
qui font des souliers qui vont prendre
environ 30 heures 150 heures donc il y
en a pas 5000 au monde
on a la chance en france d'avoir des
très grands noms comme stéphane gimenez
à bordeaux qui est un très très grand
bottier raillé pour ses fans gimenez
d'un nombre de la batterie mon cher
c'est nous a vraiment quelqu'un qui a un
oeil qui fait déborder des soudeurs
toute beauté on à pierre corthay bien
sûr qu'il ya qui a été le patron de
l'atelier berluti mais aussi par exemple
bio et fukuda japonais sont très forts
bien sûr sont forts dans beaucoup de
domaines particuliers dans ce sujet là
par exemple chez io est fukuda si vous
voulez un soulier sur mesure il faut
attendre un an et demi pas pour recevoir
le soulier pour avoir le droit
le commet des exactions listes
d'attentes et donc s'élever ferrari
quand exactement
donc c'est un livre qui parle
spécifiquement de cet artisanat qui est
assez proche de l'art parce que un vrai
souliers mesure et c'est là où je pense
qu'on l'a voulue avec le 10 juillet à
faire un livre différent
c'est par un livre qu à vous expliquer
comment on fait un soulier sépare l'île
fait aux expliqué on à quel moment faire
un trou comme on a eu plein de livres
faite sur le sujet sain on a voulu à
faire réaliser ça nous a pris beaucoup
de temps
c'est à dire voilà est-ce que pour la
première fois on pourrait pas faire le
pont un tout petit peu entre le souliers
masculins et le monde de la sculpture
parce que somme toute on n'est pas si
loin
vous savez qu'à souliers sur mesure
commence normalement avec un morceau de
bois et c'est le travail qu'on appelle
due forme y est c'est à dire il va
commencer avec un morceau de bois il va
mesurer votre pied à toutes ces
caractéristiques
donc vous savez on les êtres humains
nous sommes pas parfaits donc on n'a
jamais le même pied à gauche et à droite
l'un peut être plus long la bête weafer
et c est à partir d'un morceau de bois
il va interpréter avec des outils alors
là
hantée diluvien dérape décidé sabres à
il va interpréter avec un morceau de
bois ce qu'on appelle une forme est sûre
cette forme là il va commencer à mettre
du cuir et à coudre c'est un travail qui
est s'est littéralement de la sueur du
sang et des larmes c'est extrêmement
complexe et ces gens là font un travail
absolument remarquable
on a voulu avec handi voile à le rendre
hommage en disant aujourd'hui il ya une
passion c'est vrai c'est pas moi qui
l'inventé j'ai pas écrit ce livre par
opportunisme
il ya un vrai regain d'intérêt pour les
belges et c'est vrai pour les bourses ou
d'autant plus que pour la première fois
il ya presque une génération entière
aujourd'hui qui n'a jamais porté ce
genre de chaussures
oui n'importe quelles chaussures en cuir
c'est la révolution des baskets mais il
y en a d'ailleurs un sur cinq ici qu'il
ya des baskets
oui je ne dirai pas lequel beaucoup
porter moi même quand c'est vrai oui et
non c'est à dire qu'il ya une génération
qui ne sait pas ce que ça fait de mettre
ses pieds dans une chaussure en cuir oui
et il trouve ça très douloureux très
pénible wind il ya aussi une génération
qui l'amène qui est en train de
redécouvrir justement et c'est là où
nous on essaye alors on n'est pas là
pour pour protéger absolument dire à
tout le monde il faut acheter les weston
et où acheter des chaussures en cuir
mais est d'ailleurs l'expliqué un truc
c'est la révolution des speakers aller
assez facile à comment dire a expliqué
quand on est une grande marque de luxe
quand il faut 80 heures à la main pour
vendre un objet ou même même disons 20
heures à la machine pendant l'un objet
de 1000 euros quand il faut dix minutes
pendant le même objet en basket qu'elle
fait en italie à 2000 euros quand même
fond c'est parce qu'au lieu pour le
marié il ya là de cette notion derrière
mais on a énormément on a même une armée
de jeunes gens qui justement re découvre
le plaisir de mettre un gros souliers en
cuir et un beau souliers en cuir alors
encore une fois je ne prêche pas pour ma
paroisse mais essayez d'aller voir ça
change la vie d'un seul court ce sont
presque invulnérable à la seule petite
différence est votre avis sur fond de
moi des doc martins qui sont peut-être
les socios le foot confortable non mais
ça c'est un autre sujet parce que les
manceaux les chasseurs de constance
devrait nous
c'est une chaussure mythique et sur le
que j'adore moi personnellement j'en ai
porté plus souvent qu'à mon tour n'est
donc la populariser par les punks
oui oui oui mais est donc aujourd'hui il
ya une nouvelle génération de gens qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet et surtout il
ya moi je suis petit-fils de beauté dont
vous savez je suis un peu tombé dans la
marmite quand j'étais gamin j'avais mon
grand-père littéralement avec les mains
en sang faire des bottes d'équitation il
faisait les bottes d'équitation pour le
cadre noir a sonné l'école de cavalerie
et je peux vous jurer qu'à l'époque on
vient de sa gagne pas beaucoup d'argent
c'est un petit col bleu aujourd'hui à
quelques boîtiers star ans avec une box
internet ça peut coûter sur mesure 17
villes ou 20000 euros
mon grand pas donc mon grand père a
gagné pas du tout ça c'est un métier de
cols bleus faisait ça en bleu au bleu de
chauffe et je me souviens de voir
souffrir sur sur l' ouvrage auxerre
l'éthique c'est c'est extrêmement
intéressant que ce métier petit à petit
il ya une nouvelle génération d'hommes
de gamins qui ont envie de la prendre
bon il a les deux tiers qui font demi
tour au bout de deux mois se séduire
c'est pas un métier extrêmement valeurs
je vous interromps ont fait une pause et
on se retrouve juste après on continue
de parler de chaussures avec hugo
jacomet
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches consacré cette semaine à vos
prévisions ollier quand je fais des
scénarios je le souhaite pas forcément
m'a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui essaie de lutter contre l'hégémonie
américaine assez paradoxalement je pense
que la chine est plus dangereux que
l'iran je pense qu'on a un pays qui est
aux abois savez quand les guerres se
déclenchent elles se déclenche toujours
parce que les gens ils ont intérêt à
être 4e prévisions à lebrac cité un
éclatement de la zone euro non moi je
crois pas du tout à un éclatement de la
zone euro et j'attends même avec une
certaine impatience l'entrée de l'ecosse
dans la zone euro alors je ne sais pas
si les causes va rétablir la frontière
est embêté la reine d'angleterre mais en
revanche l'union européenne va avoir
quelques soucis en 2020 mais c'est bien
dit la crise est derrière nous donc à
huy donc la crise de l'euro est derrière
nous tant que le fmi
je sais que pour olivier saluer faire
vibrer
[Musique]
mais
à quels types d'élèves s'adresse cette
nouvelle proposition éducative les
enfants que nous allons recevoir nous au
cours des frères montgolfier sont ceux
qui n'ont pas atteint le seuil qui leur
permet d'être reconnu
ces élèves sont des élèves finalement on
a soupçonné qui s'était dyspraxiques
dyslexique enfants intellectuellement
précoces nous travaillons et c'est là
notre réussite
non pas qu'ils aient un examen mais
qu'ils aient la capacité de revenir
d'une manière très confortable sur le
terrain classique tant qu'on n'aura pas
compris que nous avons nous sommes en
train de vivre un énorme tournant et un
énorme bouleversement de la pratique
d'être professeur aujourd'hui et demain
nous aurons un mal être
une somme à train de former des adultes
de demain il faut comprendre que la
france de nos banlieues et la france et
qu'il faut l'a formé et qui ne désire
que cela
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui jean-louis
game 1 pour trop beau pour être vrai
constance debré pour son nouveau roman
love me tender le pianiste guillaume
vincent pour son nouvel album black list
et hugo jacomet l'auteur de souliers une
passion masculine avec des photos dans
ledit julia vous parlez vous êtes à
qu'elle s'est au fil en fait j'ai appris
le mot anglais dans votre livre jouer
lequel s'est au fil c'est le sait les
amateurs de choisir éclairé voire même
obsessionnel de chaussure alors ça c'est
une troupe de jean moi j'ai fait partie
de ces gens là il ya deux choses que
j'adore faire dans la vie qui vont
étonner beaucoup de gens c'est repasser
mes chemises
c'est au moment où j'ai la vapeur ça
sent bon je me sens bien et sirem et mes
souliers et c'est devenu pour beaucoup
de gens une espèce de moment un petit
peu suspendu dans le temps comme ça et
j'aime sirène et souliers et donc ses
deux salles de naissance à des vous
savez c'était le début de l'internet
nous on a eu la chance de réunir une
grosse communauté autour de nous
pourquoi parce qu'on était parmi les
premiers on est au milieu des années
2000 à la blogosphère est encore
balbutiante et puis sommes tout aussi
bon à ce sujet bien de l'élégance
masculine les classiques c'est un peu
triviale toussaint comme sujet et puis
il y avait une place à prendre donc on
la prison l'assiette donner un peu de
profondeur au sujet et donc j'ai
expliqué j'ai fait des vidéos sur le
sujet en disant voilà comment comme chez
beauty avoir il ya des légendes chez
d'un outil ouvriers berluti c'est comme
ça qu'elle a rencontrées dans l'art
arnaud est là le club swan l'époque si
la seconde d'hommes d'affaires venait
cirer leurs chaussures voilà est en fait
il se retrouvait en chaussettes pour la
paix et le comble du chic et aide avant
de chausser de trous évidemment puisque
c'est comme ça que ça se faisait
et il y avait même donc toute espèce de
comment dire prête des légendes autour
de ça comme quoi on finissait toujours
don pérignon lorsque personnellement je
préfère le boire mois donc gagnants
plutôt que si rien est chaud sur avec
mais il fallait par exemple les enterrer
un jour de pleine lune pour avoir une
pâti d'importants olga berluti a raconté
beaucoup d'histoires mais elle avait ce
génie
réinjecter du rêve mais il ya dans les
rituels par exemple là on voit des
photos géantes du sur mesure oui et pour
moi les chaussures noires on l'aimé en
ville oui les chaussures marron mais on
l'aimait l'accompagnent à lorsque vous
logique puisque on se dit c'est pour
éviter que s'il ya de la terre ça se
voit pas alors que ça le ferait s'il
avait été noir etc
c'est plus vrai du tout alors le vous
faites référence à londres c'était
vraiment c'est très anglais c'est à dire
mais c'était une époque révolue
c'était une époque où les gens avaient
une activité de jour à la campagne et
venez venez en ville le soir
tout ça est révolu maintenant on est
plus sur une notion de goût comprenez et
dates des idées aux voleurs ou david
moyes mettre des chaussures noires avec
un costume clair c'est pas terrible
depuis très récemment je vois énormément
notamment chez les jeunes générations et
des costumes bleu avec des avec des
chaussures marron voir des chaussures un
peu à la berluti d'ailleurs
alors ça c'est le boulot c'est la
révolution de la patine mais c'est là où
on essaie de nous aussi de pondérer
c'est à dire que ce sont des gens qui
l'ont redécouvert le soulier et qui d'un
seul coup envie de les montrer et donc
tranche aa dessin avec leurs souliers
moi j'ai vu des choses même pire que ça
j'ai vu des gens en costume en grande
mesure avec des baskets roses et bleus
au sommet mais pendant très longtemps je
trouvais ça horrible
m costume bleu avec des chaussures
marron et finalement on habite change
mais je sais peut-être pas si mal mais
j'ai moi même des chaussures marron
joseph vous voulez quoi vous dénoncez
bas je le ferai des faits belles
chaussures d'ailleurs de chez bon tony
alors cette maison est assez étonnante
parce que bon tennis se sont alors là
moi ce que j'aime dans tout ça mais ce
taddei c c'est là c'est tout ce qui se
passe autour donc tony c'est une saynète
de souliers fait à la main à long terme
en héros dans la région des marches ça
s'invente pas en italie et s'est fait
dans un sous-sol littéralement d'une
famille et le monsieur qui est formiez
donc il fait les formes de ses souliers
là et luthier aussi donc il fait 10 au
sud et 10 souliers pardon et un violon
c'est à dire qu'il alterne et voilà je
trouve ça il ya des personnalités
vraiment étonnante dont vous souliers
parce que on est vraiment à mi chemin
entre l'art réelle sert des gens qui
vont faire des choses très étonnante au
niveau des formes très intéressante au
niveau décousu tout est comment dire
il ya encore une innovation
extraordinaire dans le sujet et en même
temps avec qui sont simplement des
artisans dire qu'ils n'ont pas cette
note aurel sauf qu'elle est pas encore d
sa part accordé pas encore dessin bien
que des gens comme gimenez corte fukuda
ou georges peverley par exemple en
angleterre où il ya des dyades il ya des
gens très très célèbre quand même dans
le monde du soulier sonde est venue
quand même des gens des superstars
mondiales souliers une passion masculine
ça vient de paraître chez gründ et ça
pèse combien le livre s'appelle the two
croit un tout petit peu moins de 4 kg
quand même
[Musique]
constance debré vous êtes l'auteur de
playboy un livre c'était votre premier
roman dans lequel vous enchaîniez les
aventures homosexuelles après avoir été
mariée pendant assez longtemps et avoir
eu un petit garçon
aujourd'hui vous publiez love me tender
c'est un peu la suite au fond même si on
peut le lire sans avoir lu playboy c'est
toujours chez flammarion alors dans ce
livre là votre fils qui a 8 ans ne vous
aime plus ne veut plus vous voir et il
se trouve que c'est juste au moment où
vous avez demandé à son cas le divorce
oui c'est là c'est la suite c'est la
suite des aventures ou pas ou pas du
tout la suite
moi j'ai voulu écrire un livre d'amour
en fait oui c'est d'où le titre de petit
avec avec
avec la dureté aussi qui peut y avoir il
peut y avoir dans l'amour alors il est
question d'amour maternel ou filiales
céline et voilà mais pas que et oui
c'est 7
c'est aussi je parlais je parlais de mer
au début et c'est la question quand on
se lance dans le voyage on y va aussi
peut-être pour pour les épreuves sans le
savoir ou en sachant consciemment ou
inconsciemment j'en sais rien et est la
narratrice kaki et moi si on veut mais
moi je ne le prends dans ma vie il faut
pour faire un livre ensuite et
et
qui est qui et qui est une histoire qui
est ce voyage là
et la narratrice 2,9 me tender va subir
nombre d'épreuves et notamment un
conflit en tout cas là
oui le questionnement de de sa relation
avec avec son fils
parce que moi je crois pas tellement aux
grands discours sur l'amour peut parler
de l'amour l'amour maternel
en réalité on n'en dira jamais rien
toujours la même chose des discours qui
disent pas la réalité
je crois qu'un amour c'est quelque chose
c'est une histoire voilà c'est aussi un
voyage et qui peut vivre qui peut
qui peut être traverser des preuves des
épreuves qui parle de l'amour
qu'éprouvent les intéressés mais qui
parle aussi de désintéresser en
l'occurrence de soi puisque la grande
question mon avis c'est toujours ça
c'est soit comme vous parler de divorce
a enfin votre votre héroïne parle de
divorce au père de son fils ça se
passait bien jusque là avec son fils si
vous aviez il avait les deux parents
avaient la garde partagée et le fils ne
reprochez strictement rien à sa mère
quand bien même il avait compris qu'elle
avait des histoires d'amour avec des
femmes
et puis elle demande le divorce à son
père est hélas le père la cus d'inceste
et on sait que depuis un certain nombre
d'années depuis une vingtaine d'années
d'ailleurs une recrudescence
d'accusation d'inceste
dès qu'il ya des affaires de divorce
sont généralement les mères qui accuse
les pères d'inceste on sait aussi qu'un
un bon nombre qui ce sont de fausses
allégations
enfin c'est plus rare que ce soit la
marque qui se retrouve sous le feu de
cette accusation vous le dit d'ailleurs
vous dites qu'il s'agit d'un vrai crime
de mecs presque une reconnaissance pour
une meuf
c'est vrai que je chasse sur leurs
terres dites vous oui alors pour le coup
je crois que le les divorcés y voir ce
qui se passe mal sont sont la banalité
des vies modernes il ya peu de romans là
dessus d'ailleurs marqué un pas alors
que c'est parce qu'il y en aura de plus
il y en aura certainement de plus en
plus on fait le lieu on sait comment
sont les pères sur les maires sur les
frères b très peu sur les divorces sont
nos guerres modernes petite guerre
moderne très souvent ça d'ailleurs quand
j'étais avocat au moi je faisais du
pénal et pas de papa du droit de la
famille parce que je trouvais ça trop
violent pénale
voilà le corps était déjà froid premiers
pas les divorcés participé à la guerre
mais
oui alors ça je crois que pour ce qui
est de la violence a les dents dans le
cadre d'un divorce elle peut être
également répartie entre les hommes et
les femmes
s'il ya peut-être plus d'accusation
d'inceste de la part des femmes c'est
qu'on y pense plus volontiers de la part
des hommes en revanche peut y avoir des
allégations et je crois qu'il y en a
aussi beaucoup de mauvaise vie
d'immoralité de la part des hommes
contre les femmes est là dans mon cas ou
dans le cas du livre les choses se
mêlent et je pense que consciemment ou
inconsciemment l' accusation d'inceste
me concernant concernant la narratrice
effectivement bien sûr se fasse au
greffe sur l'homosexualité de la
narratrice et on va mettre une
transgression interdite sur une
transgression autorisé et pour le coût
réel et mais vous dites aussi que va
jouer cette ambiguïté au fond c'est pas
tellement que vous aviez les femmes qui
est le problème c'est le fait que en
choisissant cette vie un moment quittant
votre mari au fond vous avez aussi
renoncé à tout le reste c'est à dire à
votre métier d'avocat à l'argent à un
certain confort bourgeois ou qu'elle
vous étiez habitués de votre depuis
votre enfance
ainsi relatif et quand on a lu un
playboy oui c'est vrai qu'avec des
parents comme très spéciaux enfin
appartenant comme vous le savez votre
cas une dynastie est célèbre en france
et qu on plaque sur la bourgeoisie en bd
et il faut c'est devenu une sorte d'
asset quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'argent qui
s'en fout qui squatte chez les uns et
chez les autres quand c'est nécessaire
ce serait ça au fond qui poseraient
vraiment problème
oui je crois que je crois qu'on a vu
dans
ma manière de vivre qui est pas une
revendication ou un discours politique
qui est simplement
plutôt à ne pas que qu'autres choses ne
pas et ne pas quoi ne pas la famille ne
pas
la consommation enfin moi ça m'est égal
encore une fois c'est pas un discours
politique et ne pas ne pas le travail
enfin au sens de travail rémunéré une
activité de cet ordre puisque écriture
en est un mais c'est autre chose
et oui et ça ça je crois que c'est c'est
vu comme soit une transgression c'est à
dire non non je veux pas vivre la vie
qu'il faudrait vivre c'est à dire voilà
travail et avoir une famille elle
devrait se sente seul acceptait la
limite de quelqu un de seuls mais de
quelqu'un qui a un enfant mais à salir
ses dirigeants
en réalité je crois que ce qui est ce qu
est-ce qui est pas compris c'est
c'est le changement voilà c'est qu'on
soit un endroit quelque part bon ben
voilà on en aura banal cochez les cases
peu près normale du boulot de la famille
marie machin était en cours du bas n'ont
finalement moi je je vais changer
d'endroit
je suis un bon ben là on n'y comprend
rien donc soit c'est un scandale et
avoir un crime soit c'est une trahison
du camp précédent enfin cesser c'est ça
c'est inacceptable
il faut savoir où sont les gens et
appartements où on décide de bouger
je crois que c'est effectivement assez
mal vu en tout cas moi je sais comme ça
que c'est comme ça j'avais vécu oui je
pense que c'est c'est l'accumulation des
changements ou des transgressions qui
est vu comme un tremplin
vous dites dans ce livre constance debré
que vous avez rajeuni on gagne 10 ans
dites vous
en devenant homos c'est un peu c'est
dorian gray quoi ce n'est absolument pas
comment l expliquez vous je ne
m'explique pas mais le public
vous avez changé de camp dix ans de
moins
ça ne vous aura pas échappé que c'est un
peu une audace et ben c'est pas d'une
grave c'est vrai je me suis dit la même
chose mais il faut changer de camp pour
ça j'en sais rien en tout cas
bon ben je crois qu'il ya un effet il ya
un effet revigorant de la nouveauté ça
toujours actuelle c'est peut-être ça oui
c'est peut-être et il ya toute cette
histoire de faux rapports avec votre
fils qui évidemment émail émaillent le
roman parce que évidemment la mer va
revoir son fils alors c'est très encadré
parce qu'on l'a accusée d'inceste donc
tout à coup il ya des associations qui
sont là des membres des associations qui
sont là pour encadrer la rencontre on
sait jamais si vous essayez de mettre
enfin bon et et puis à et puis ça se
passe très bien au fond et elle se rend
compte l'héroïne que évidemment c'est
parce qu'il a voulu faire plaisir à son
père que il a dit que ça se passait bel
abbès examen qui voulait plus la voir
etc
c'est le cas dans tous les divorces qui
est des affaires comme celle-ci
non je pense que ça c'est pas le cas
dans tous les divorces et chaque
histoire est différente mais oui je
crois que ce qu'on appelle l'expression
est maintenant je crois assez assez
banal et connue de beaucoup conflit de
loyauté
un enfant qui est déchiré entre deux
parents c'est quelque chose d'assez
banal et l'enfant essaye de faire
plaisir à l'un à l'autre ou plus à l'un
qu'à l'autre et ils sont commis peuvent
les pauvres
et chacun son histoire et dans la
moi j'essaye de raconter l'histoire
d'abord l'histoire de ceux de cette
période de conflit et d'absence et
l'histoire de ce chagrin je raconte que
ça je raconte pas avant je raconte ma
après j'essaye de ne pas mettre à la
place des autres dans ce livre je ne
mets pas la place de du père je donne
les faits je ne suis pas là ni pour le
juge est nue pour essayer d'expliquer
pourquoi il agit comme ça je me mets pas
à la place de l'enfant pour savoir ce
que lui pense vraiment ce qu'il éprouve
c'était les anciens romancier du 19e
siècle qui se mettait à la place de tout
le monde
et pourquoi pas mais les romanciers du
20e et encore moins du 21e et le fond
cette imagination et ce talent ni cette
générosité
d'ailleurs j'en sais rien ça donnait des
plus gros livre aussi audi quand on se
mettait à la place de tous bords mais
non simplement de donner de prendre les
éléments objectifs de ne pas entourer
ces événements qui sont
incompréhensibles de discours juste
juste les laisser là et de voir comment
comment
comment on traverse le temps bien sûr
mais avec des éléments qui sont
extrêmement contradictoires pour un ara
triste qui reçoit des éléments d'abord
la7 cette sorte de de certitude ça je
crois que quand on quand on est mais
quand on aimait d'un enfant c'est
quelque chose qu'on sait au plus profond
de soi et en même temps des éléments qui
viennent contredire cette certitude donc
quelque chose qui pourrait rendre fou
plus notre d'autres éléments qui
pourraient rendre fou c'est à dire c'est
c'est évidemment le processus judiciaire
qui est d'une grande violence qu'elle
connaissait comme avocat mais pas comme
accusé si je le dire ça c'est aussi un
changement classe qui est pas qui est
assez violent mais pas inintéressant on
va dire
et
et en même temps parallèle votre héroïne
non seulement elle subit tout ce que
vous racontez mais elle qui était resté
un peu comme dans playboy
une femme qui a enchaîné les aventures
au fond elle va finir quand même par à
mort vit peut-être éventuel bon c'est
pas mon père a ensuite mais pourquoi pas
de tomber amoureuse donc on peut dire ça
on peut pas dire que ce soit un grand
succès dès maintenant
certes mais il ya quand même il ya le
love me tender n'est pas seulement
familiale aux alors oui c'est à dire que
dans le dans le dans le vide et le et le
le déséquilibrer le désarroi que crès ce
ce choc cette violence et ce chagrin un
de cette procédure
tout ça dans un mouvement encore une
fois de quand même de dépouillement de
tara général
il va falloir remplir le vide donc ça on
le remplit
halak semble aventure est aussi dans
l'idée de battre puisqu'on peut
déconstruire puisque les places ne sont
finalement pas si fixe peut-être qu'on
peut aussi déconstruire ce truc de
l'amour qui ne devrait se décliner que
sous forme conjugale est monogame alors
pourquoi pas alors voilà elle essaye
aussi pourquoi pas et puis et puis après
oui effectivement va y avoir une
relation plus importante + plus qu'à
plus de 100 tu accuses d'amour mais qui
va qui va ou qui va échouer enfin qu'il
a échoué non je ne sais pas ce que je
vois jamais les choses comme un échec
boîte on le voit pas qui va se terminer
c'est pas un échec je fais belle love me
tender essais signés constance debré et
c'est paru chez flammarion
[Musique]
guillaume vincent vous êtes pianiste
vote représente album était consacrée à
rachmaninoff aujourd'hui vous sortez
blacklist chez naïve alors on connaît
liste franz liszt
mais black list indépendamment du jeu
debout qui par ailleurs axe excellent
vous faites allusion à quoi dans black
list
mais ce que je voulais et c'est ce que
je souhaite en tant que musicien le plus
possible c'est tout simplement de faire
découvrir des oeuvres peu connues en
tant que pianiste et plus généralement
dans la musique classique il ya beaucoup
voilà beaucoup d'oeuvres un peu mise de
côté dirons-nous liste à composer des
centaines d'oeuvres son répertoire est
gigantesque
alors j'ai voulu j'ai voulu tout
simplement concocté un programme que
voilà que peu de gens jouaient peu de
gens enregistré peu de gens écouter mais
voilà au sein du grand public et d'où
les jeux de mots évidemment fait ya
quand même des il ya des tubes de liste
milliards quand même on va entendre la
balade numéro deux ans les gens la
connaissent
ja il ya une illusion à chopin aussi
vous êtes intéressé à ce qui compose
juste après la mort de chopin plus
particulièrement et c'est pas que tous
et toutes ces pièces ont été composées
entre 1850 et 1860 soit peu après la
mort de chopin qui est mort en 49 et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque part un peu
un hommage à frédéric chopin qui était
très proche spirituellement de franz
liszt d'ailleurs chopin convoi est juste
derrière vous lé voilà la seule
photographie de frédéric chopin qui
avait l'air un peu tendu d'ailleurs sur
cette photo
alors il est mort jeune il est mort il
est mort très jeune bien sûr et donc
voila moi ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
donc de m évidemment cet hommage c'est
cette inspiration en regard quand on
quand on regarde par exemple la majeur k
brillante de liste on sait que chopin a
été le premier à composer des mazurkas
dans la musique classique ainsi que
l'hébreu l'aise on peut penser que
l'affluence de chocques pas aussi on va
écouter deux gitanes extrait de la la
balade numéro 2 évidemment ça évoque
chopin on vous écoute
[Musique]
e
oh
liste est née en 1811 cheveux en 1810
sont deux stars énorme pour elles les
deux on parle de lisztomania c'est à
dire c'est l'équivalent des beatles pour
l'époque a été le premier d'ailleurs à
faire des concerts oui c'est l'époque où
le pianiste virtuose improvisateur et
compositeur vraiment en remplit les
salles liszt et chopin sont deux stars
sont ils sont deux amis aussi des amis
bien que leur caractère soi soit très
différent je pars était plus fragile ça
sentait d'ailleurs était plus beaucoup
plus fragile quant à liszt il a souvent
une puissance presque métaphysique dans
sa musique quand on prend la deuxième
balade par exemple c'est une pièce qui
dure 15 minutes
mais parce qu'on vient ça lui convient
voilà on remarque déjà beaucoup de
beaucoup de couleurs très différentes et
puis liste moi ce qui me fascine ce qui
m'a toujours fasciné chez liszt
c'est que c'est un compositeur avec
énormément de facettes voilà on l'a
à cette époque là il était au sommet de
son art évidemment c'était c'est
effectivement la star mais on sait que
liszt par exemple à la fin de sa vie a
composé des oeuvres un peu plus
impressionniste par exemple comme les
jeux deauville à la villa d'este
et puis à la fin de sa vie il s'est
reconverti carrément en tant qu'abbé
dans des pièces dans notre pièce fut
religieuse d'alsace qui disait de liste
il disait le hongrois est un démon et le
polonais y paris chopin est un ange
oui d'accord oui puis il ya souvent ce
rapport mi ange mi démon dans la musique
de liszt et moi cette voie là c'est
vraiment ce qui me plaît le plus je
crois puis voilà pour revenir à chopin
on sait que effectivement je pense que
chopin a suivi liste son inspiration
toute sa vie on écoute un autre extrait
de cet album c'est le liban est rom
numéro 3 là aussi on peut comprendre
entendre l'influencent de shop vous
écoute
[Musique]
où
et
je
[Musique]
ce qui est ce que je trouve très
frappante quand on écoute de ceux liste
là où chopin de la même époque
c'est à quel point c'est plus la musique
des seigneurs c'est plus la musique
religieuse c'est vraiment la musique de
la bourgeoisie c'est la musique de
l'intimité c'est la musique des jeunes
filles qui apprennent le piano c'est la
musique d'un appartement pour la
première forme là des chambres à coucher
on a de la qualité de la solitude et
c'est cette musique là qui en est la
parfaite illustration
absolument oui quand on écoute pour
revenir à chopin les nocturnes dans ce
disque il ya aussi la berceuse qui
d'ailleurs a été composé dans la même
tonalité que celle de chopin
là aussi on peut y voir un hommage il il
ya une douceur il a quelque chose
d'extrêmement à la fois cristallin
presque aquatique
on est dans une sensualité c'était toute
une époque
absolument fascinante et puis voilà qui
contraste parfois avec des pièces
complètement complètement différentes
listes était aussi un grand
transcripteur il a transcrit toutes les
symphonies de beethoven il ya plus de
400 transcription transcription c'est
quand on prend toute une série finit
avec plein d'instruments il avait une
avec le piano est censé représenter leur
qu'istres et pour terminer guillaume
vincent petit clin d'oeil il ya une de
vos oeuvres que j'aime beaucoup vous
aussi vous êtes capable d'improviser
ce sont vos variations sur un thème de
la sncf que vous avez enregistré et et
qu'on a filmé dans une gare l avantage
avec la grève c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
temps à passer dans la lah et mais il se
trouve que sur ces trois notes que les
gens attendent très souvent quand ils
attendent un train qui n'arrive pas on
connaît tous le parc
voilà vous avez réalisé ça
[Musique]
et
en
ah ah
et
oh
m
et
voilà c'est enregistré est la gare de
lyon je vous remercie tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission black
list
le nouvel album de guillaume vincent est
sorti chez naïve et vous serez en
concert dimanche matin à waterloo samedi
25 janvier à franconville les jeudis 30
à arsenic de mons toujours en belgique
love me tender le nouveau roman de
constance de brécé chez flammarion
souliers une passion masculine de hugo
jacomet cd type t'es chez gründ est trop
beau pour être vrai de jean-louis game 1
sécher le passage merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
et